what's that in volantis and the cities
that are oing they take all of the
people afflicted with greyscale and they
dump that mounted in a ruler city I
suppose this is it then the doom still
rules Valyria it calcifies the skin of
basically it turns into stone and the
stone is maybe thin at first so you can
move and it kind of cracks and breaks
like a thin layer of ice there's always
fear that if you have any contact with
the stone man you contract the disease
yourself many of them touch you it's a
death sentence here but it's a slow
death sentence and if it affects the
brain at all of course it also brings
with it madness two of my sisters had it
they both died we heard them especially
at night they started to sound not like
themselves there's not much of in
Westeros so it does occur from time to
time everyone advised me to send you to
the ruins of Valyria to live out your
short life with the stone men before the
sickness spread through the castle and
that's essentially their leper colony a
haunted place dark and mysterious with
mists hanging over stone man as they're
called wandering through the fog until
they die few afflictions are more feared
than greyscale and far past the point of
reason a legend calls it Prince garin's
curse after an ancient eastern prince
whom the Valyrians hung in a cage and
forced to watch the emulation of his
city and people as his city burned under
dragon flame this Prince called on his
God for vengeance and a thick fog of
foul humors rose from the Rhoyne to
smother the Valyrians with greyscale but
if diseases could be caught down by the
vengeful we'd have no health in the
world more likely the disease predates
the Valerians entirely confined to some
remote region of Essos and only spread
throughout the world
once the Valyrians linked the continent
with robes
Dragons the disease begins as a rash the
afflicted flesh stiffens calcifies and
cracks and assumes the diseases nominal
human victims are graciously spared pain
as the disease does sensation in the
infected limbs but the disease is
insidious and slowly it creeps over the
skin and into the organs once the
infection reaches the brain feral
madness replaces humanity and the
transformation to a stone map is
complete there is no consensus on
treatment some masters advocate of
mustard poultices vinegar rinses and
scalding hot baths others claim only
three cures axe sword and cleaver
hacking off afflicted parts does
sometimes stop the spread of the disease
but not always many a man has sacrificed
an arm or foot only to find the other
going gray those who have been
miraculously cured of greyscale a few
and usually were subjected to so many
treatments that isolating the
responsible cure is impossible besides
few maesters priests or healers have the
courage for such experiments as would
prove a cure greyscale is highly
contagious being known to spread from
even the slightest contact with an
infected person hence the current
occupation of Valyria by the stone men
exiled from their homelands at the first
sign of the disease what they do there
with their final months or even years
for greyscale is a slow killer
no one knows no one wants to find out